Les autorités [musiques]
ont lancé une
chasse à l'homme dans plusieurs États pour William Butcher si quelqu'un
aperçoit William Butcher ou l'un de ses
associés connus Marvin Milk que
Campbell ou cet homme appelle s'il vous plaît un
huit huit huit zéro cri
[Applaudissements] Le
monde a encore besoin de super-héros alors
allons-y  là-bas, faisons
tomber ces [ __ ], nous sommes tous célèbres non ne
t'inquiète pas, la maison de papa c'est un
[ __ ] de bordel
avec le plus de gars d'eau du pays
alors quel est ton grand projet tu vas adorer je
ne l'aimerai pas je n'aime jamais  [ __ ], je ne l'ai jamais
aimé. Non
[Musique]
tu n'es pas deux fois chanceux que je t'ai montré toi